This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。当有自动扶梯可用时，只有这个数字的人会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中心智坚韧、健身和建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字的2百分之百，在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难中学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行那些在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人带着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难中学习》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了测试一次。这需要一队网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被爱困住》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《被爱困住》播客。大家好，欢迎回到你的二十岁心理学，这是一个我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型及其意义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you back here for another episode. This week, I thought we tackle a subject that I'm sure is really pertinent for a lot of us at the moment, and that is the struggle with perfectionism, particularly as it relates to academic anxiety, but also in so many other realms of our lives. The interesting thing about this topic for me is that perfectionism is often interpreted as a good thing and an overall positive quality. How many of us have wrote that you have strong attention to detail on our resumes or talked about your perfectionist traits in a job interview? it's widely valued and viewed in society as a positive thing, something that we would like to have.
为了我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。本周，我想我们探讨一个我相信目前对我们许多人都非常相关的主题，那就是与完美主义的斗争，特别是与学业焦虑相关的完美主义，同时也涉及到我们生活的许多其他领域。这个话题对我来说有趣的地方在于，完美主义通常被解释为一件好事和一种整体上积极的品质。我们中有多少人在简历上写过你对细节有很强的关注，或者在求职面试中谈到过你的完美主义特质？它在社会中受到广泛重视，并被视为一件积极的事情，是我们希望拥有的东西。
So we don't always second guess its use and what it actually means for our behaviour, particularly for people in their 20s, as is obviously the whole entire purpose of this show. But what does psychology actually say about this trait? What does it actually say about perfectionism? I'm going to spoil some of the research for you all. already, but if you haven't guessed it, perfectionism can be incredibly stifling and restrictive in the pursuit of both our short-term goals, such as finishing an assignment, getting things done, completing the things on our to-do list, but also our longer-term goals, all the way up
因此，我们并不总是会重新审视它的用途以及它对我们行为的实际意义，特别是对于二十多岁的人来说，这显然是这个节目的全部目的。但是心理学对这种特质到底是怎么说的呢？它对完美主义到底是怎么说的？我要为你们剧透一些研究成果。已经，但如果你还没有猜到的话，完美主义在追求我们的短期目标（如完成一项作业、把事情做完、完成待办人员名单上的事情）时，可能会非常令人窒息和限制，甚至我们的长期目标，一直到
to graduating university, choosing a career path, and even creating successful relationships. there are some surprising emotional and mental health consequences that I think aren't spoken about enough when we talk about perfectionism. And more broadly, there are a number of misconceptions about this concept that I think need to be broken down because that colloquial use to describe perfectionism as positive, it really does reinforce some pretty negative behaviours. And in reality, there really isn't much about the fact that. this quality that is healthy. In fact, it's very much a dangerous, maladaptive coping mechanism
大学毕业、选择职业道路，甚至是建立成功的关系。有一些令人惊讶的情绪和心理健康后果，我认为当我们谈论完美主义时，这些后果没有得到足够的讨论。更广泛地说，关于这个概念存在许多误解，我认为这些误解需要被打破，因为用来形容完美主义是积极的这种通俗用法，确实巩固了一些相当消极的行为。而现实中，关于这个事实其实并没有太多。这种品质是健康的。事实上，它在很大程度上是一种危险的、适应不良的应对机制
for dealing with failure and for dealing with criticism from others. And it's on the rise, particularly amongst young people. As far as our 20s are concerned, the presence of perfectionism is very important to discuss as it relates to a number of our experiences, including our body image. If you listen to the episode on eating disorders or diet culture, you'll already know that people with certain conditions like anorexia are much more likely to be perfectionist compared to the average individual, but also people-pleasing tendencies and the one I really want to focus on today, academic performance and academic anxiety. Most of us in our 20s, I would assume, are in some kind of further study or you have done further study and although it is a slug for most of us
用于应对失败以及应对来自他人的批评。而且它正在上升，特别是在年轻人当中。就我们的二十多岁而言，完美主义的存在对于讨论我们的许多经历非常重要，包括我们的身体形象。如果你听过关于饮食失调或饮食文化的某一集，你就会知道，与普通人相比，患有厌食症等特定疾病的人更有可能是完美主义者，还有讨好他人的倾向，以及我今天真正想关注的一个，学业表现和学业焦虑。我想我们二十多岁的大多数人都在进行某种深造，或者你已经完成了深造，尽管对我们大多数人来说这是一场苦战
and unenjoyable at times some of us are particularly crippled by the need to meet an exceptional standard of performance to the point that it actually causes paralysis it paralyzes our ability to start things to finish them to feel happy and successful it's like our brain is asking us for one thing, but simultaneously sabotaging our efforts. And it's a very complicated interaction. Interestingly, students who are perfectionists do typically do better in academic environments, but at a massive expense to their overall enjoyment of their studies and their overall well-being. So today, we're going to discuss everything to do with perfectionism from the origins, why some people have it and others don't.
有时并不愉快，我们中的一些人特别被需要达到异常表现标准的需要所折磨，以至于它实际上导致了瘫痪它瘫痪了我们开始事情、完成事情、感到快乐和成功的能力就像我们的大脑在向我们要一件事，但同时又在破坏我们的努力。这是一个非常复杂的互动。有趣的是，具有完美主义倾向的学生在学术环境中通常表现更好，但这却以极大地牺牲他们对学习的整体享受和整体幸福感为代价。所以今天，我们将讨论与完美主义有关的一切，从它的起源，为什么有些人有而其他人没有。
the links to personality and procrastination, how it relates to academic anxiety, and of course, what we can do about it. I think perfectionism sometimes feels like a bit of a mental prison. I'm saying that as a perfectionist myself, but we can really retrain our brains using techniques like the 80-20 method, visualization, positive self-talk to reframe the tasks on our to do list so that they seem manageable and ultimately understand that life is not about being perfect. So for my perfectionists out there, this one is for you. Let's ride this wave together and get to the bottom of the psychology and the science of perfectionism. Perfectionism, it's not the same as having high standards for ourselves or wanting to be the best that we can be. That's probably the biggest misconception
它与个性和拖延症的联系，它与学业焦虑的关系，当然，我们能对此做些什么。我认为完美主义有时感觉像是一个精神监狱。我自己作为一个完美主义者这么说，但我们可以真正通过使用诸如80-20方法、可视化、积极的自我对话等技术来重新训练我们的大脑，以重新构建我们待办事项清单上的任务，使它们看起来易于管理，并最终理解生活不是为了完美。所以对于我的完美主义者们，这一集是为你们准备的。让我们一起乘风破浪，探究完美主义的心理学和科学的底层逻辑。完美主义，它与对我们自己有高标准或想要成为最好的自己是不一样的。这可能是最大的误解。
that I want to address straight off the bat because I think this misunderstanding is a massive reason why we often think of this trait as being positive. But in the words of possibly one of my favorite people, Brunei Brown, perfectionism is not the same thing as striving to be your best. Perfectionism is not about healthy achievement and growth. It's actually about shielding or protecting ourselves against blame, against judgment or shame. That is, really at the core of what we're talking about today. But let's get our basics down, Pat, first before we jump in. Perfectionism in psychology is essentially a personality trait in which an individual is driven to appear, to feel, and to be perfect, often at the expense of their
我想从一开始就解决这个问题，因为我认为这种误解是我们经常认为这种特质是积极的的一个主要原因。但用我可能最喜欢的人之一布琳·布朗的话来说，完美主义不等同于努力做到最好。完美主义与健康的成就和成长无关。它实际上是关于保护或防范我们免受指责、评判或羞耻。这，确实是我们今天讨论的核心。但在我们深入探讨之前，先让我们把基础知识搞懂。心理学中的完美主义本质上是一种人格特质，在这种特质中，一个人被驱使着去表现、去感受和做到完美，这往往是以他们的
self-esteem. And it's not just perfection as it relates to our grades. It's perfection in all areas of life. Maybe you are a big runner, a big athlete. You can have perfectionist qualities and traits within that domain or when it comes to our body image or how much money we're making or our success. It's all related to this inherent quality. You see, perfectionism, it's not an encouraging voice in our head. It's actually quite a negative and self-critical little creature that convinces us that if we're not achieving unattainable ideals or unrealistic goals, we are a failure. And amongst people who have this trait, their self-worth is often determined by their capacity to reach these incredibly high personal standards and this causes us to push and push until we
自尊。这不仅是与我们的成绩有关的完美。它是生活各个领域的完美。也许你是一个长跑大户，一个伟大的运动员。你可以在该领域内拥有完美主义的品质和特质，或者在我们的身体形象、我们赚多少钱或我们的成功方面。这都与这种内在品质有关。你看，完美主义并不是我们脑海中一个鼓舞人心的声音。它实际上是一个相当消极和自我批判的小家伙，它说服我们，如果我们没有实现无法企及的理想或不切实际的目标，我们就是失败者。在具有这种特质的人群中，他们的自我价值往往取决于他们达到这些高得难以置信的个人标准的能力，这导致我们不断地推动，直到我们
either succeed, which is incredibly rare, or we quote unquote, fail and we burn out, resulting in this massive dip in our sense of self-worth and other behaviours like procrastination and even depression and anxiety. So in this way, it is highly maladaptive. Maladaptive being a behaviour that interferes with our ability to perform daily activities because it encompasses so many negative and self-sabotaging aspects like an intense fear of failure, unrealistic standards, only focusing on results and being intensely critical of ourselves. This really fascinating article put it in a great way. Perfectionists are held to this strange double standard in our society,
要么成功，这极其罕见，要么我们所谓的“失败”并精疲力竭，导致我们的自我价值感急剧下降，以及其他行为，如拖延症，甚至是抑郁和焦虑。因此，从这个意义上说，它是高度适应不良的。适应不良是指干扰我们进行日常活动能力的的行为，因为它包含了如此多消极和自我破坏的方面，如对失败的强烈恐惧、不切实际的标准、只关注结果以及对自己进行激烈的批判。这篇非常迷人的文章很好地阐述了这一点。完美主义者在我们社会中受到这种奇怪的双重标准，
where they are simultaneously admired for their achievements, whilst also very much criticised and not just by external forces or other people, but by themselves. So they receive all of this praise. externally, but internally they're really struggling. And it's this double standard, especially when it comes to something like academic achievement, which is universally valued in our society, that creates a very difficult cycle based on external reinforcement from society, and then an internal fear of failure, which just perpetuates the behavior. So if you are listening to this
他们一方面因自己的成就而受到钦佩，同时又受到极大的批评，不仅来自外部力量或其他外人，还来自他们自己。所以他们获得了所有这些赞扬。在外部，但在内部他们真的很挣扎。正是这种双重标准，特别是当涉及到像学业成就这样在我们社会中受到普遍重视的事情时，创造了一个基于社会外部强化的非常困难的循环，然后是对失败的内部恐惧，这只会延续这种行为。所以如果你在听这个
thinking, this is literally describing me, this is me. Let's firstly, dive a bit further into some of the signs or problematic behaviors to look out for. A big one is that you struggle to complete tasks in a timely manner or when they need to be done by. This has strong links to procrastination, which is an aspect of perfectionism will touch on later. But essentially, if you are a perfectionist, it's really hard to start something, to finish something if you don't personally believe that it's perfect. So it's a massive indicator, not that you're lazy, but that actually you set such high standards for yourself that you can't even possibly begin to try and meet them. You might also find it really hard to come back from mistakes and you
心想，这简直是在说我，这就是我。首先，让我们进一步深入探讨一些需要注意的迹象或有问题行为。一个很大的表现是，你很难及时完成任务，或者在需要完成的时候完成。这与拖延症有很强的联系，这是我们稍后会涉及的完美主义的一个方面。但本质上，如果你是一个完美主义者，如果你个人不认为它是完美的，那么开始一件事、完成一件事就真的很难。所以这是一个巨大的指标，并不是说你懒惰，而是实际上你为自己设定的标准太高了，以至于你甚至不可能开始尝试去达到它们。你可能还会发现很难从错误中恢复过来，你
ruminate on your failures rather than your successes, which can create a very toxic headspace, incredibly toxic, because if that little voice in your head is always telling you that you've never done well enough, you've never met your standards, it's going to be incredibly hard to view yourself in a positive light, and you might also have a hard time overlooking small mistakes and repeatedly going over your work, redoing your task, until it's perfect. even if it takes hours and hours, hence that maladaptive aspect. You may also feel an immense, almost out of body like pressure to live up to high expectations, both your own and others.
反刍你的失败而不是成功，这会创造一个非常糟糕的心态，极其糟糕，因为如果脑海中的那个小声音总是告诉你你永远做得不够好，你从未达到你的标准，要以积极的眼光看待自己将是极其困难的，你可能也很难忽视小错误并一遍又一遍地检查你的工作，重做你的任务，直到它是完美的。即使这需要几个小时又几个小时，因此这就是那个适应不良的方面。你可能还会感到一种巨大的、几乎像灵魂出窍一样的压力，要达到很高的期望，包括你自己的和别人的。
And additionally, you might also be hypersensitive to criticism or rejection. This is why perfectionism and people please. go hand in hand because perfectionists are highly attuned to the expectations of others and they have this intense fear of upsetting or disappointing people like their parents, people they respect, society in general, meaning that they neglect their own needs for the sake of other people. Your identity might also be highly dependent on your accomplishments and you may see yourself as a really driven person, but your failures mean a lot more to you in that they are how you judge your character. So you might admire yourself for being accomplished. Outwardly,
此外，你可能对批评或拒绝高度敏感。这就是为什么完美主义和讨好他人。齐头并进，因为完美主义者对他人的期望高度敏感，他们对 upset 或让人失望有着强烈的恐惧，比如他们的父母、他们尊重的人、总体的社会，这意味着他们为了别人的利益而忽视了自己的需求。你的身份也可能高度依赖于你的成就，你可能认为自己是一个非常有进取心的人，但你的失败对你来说意义更重大，因为那是你评价自己性格的方式。所以你可能会因为自己有所成就而钦佩自己。在表面上，
you might seem highly driven, but if someone was to take a look inside your brain, it probably wouldn't be a pretty place to be because every failure to you means the world. Finally, you may also have extremely high standards for others, which can put a lot of pressure on your personal relationships if your friends or your partner can never meet your unattainable expectations, resulting in essentially relationship breakdown. These are obviously just a few, but there are so many niche behaviours that are highly correlated
你可能显得非常有进取心，但如果有人往你的大脑内部看一眼，它可能不会是一个美好的地方，因为对你来说每一次失败都意味着全世界。最后，你对别人也可能有极高的标准，如果你的朋友或伴侣永远无法达到你那高不可攀的期望，这会对你的个人关系施加很大的压力，从而基本上导致关系破裂。这些显然只是少数，但有许多小众行为是高度相关的
with individuals who are high in the perfectionist trait, as a psychologist would say, Of course, none of these behaviours are deliberate. Perfectionism, like we mentioned at the very start, is a personality trait, meaning that it and its associated actions or habits are often innate and they have formed unconsciously and beyond our control, which is what makes it such a hard thing to treat. I think it's also interesting to point out here that there is not just one type
对于具有高完美主义特质的个人，正如心理学家所说，当然，这些行为都不是故意的。正如我们在最开始提到的那样，完美主义是一种人格特质，这意味着它及其相关的行动或习惯通常是天生的，并且是在无意识中以及超出我们控制的情况下形成的，这就是为什么它如此难以治疗。我认为在这里指出这一点也很有趣，那就是不仅仅只有一种类型
of perfectionist, but there are three. And there are two actually very important people we need to stop and acknowledge here, and that is Dr. Paul Hewitt and Dr. Gordon Flett. They are essentially the pioneers of the large majority of research into perfectionism over the last couple of decades. And one thing they found is that, like most traits, perfectionism also exists on a spectrum and it can differ in presentation for different people. The three broadcase. categories of perfectionists that they have discovered, observed, whatever word you'd like to use for it, are socially or social prescribed perfectionists, other oriented perfectionists, and finally, self-oriented perfectionist. So socially prescribed perfectionism,
完美主义者，但有三种。这里实际上有两个非常重要的人我们需要停下来并承认，那就是保罗·休伊特博士和戈登·弗利特博士。他们在过去几十年里基本上是关于完美主义的大部分研究的先驱。他们发现的一件事是，像大多数特质一样，完美主义也存在于一个光谱上，并且对于不同的人，它的表现形式可能有所不同。他们发现的、观察到的、无论你愿意用什么词来形容的完美主义的三个广泛类别。类别，是社会规定型或社会规定型完美主义，他人导向型完美主义，最后是自我导向型完美主义。所以社会规定型完美主义，
this occurs in which someone is incredibly self-critical. They feel immense pressure to be the best, and they worry that others are going to reject them, particularly important, respected people in their lives, I'm thinking parents, I'm thinking teachers. Normally, it's perceived external standards, such as academic expectations, that can lead to this version of perfectionism and the accompanying low confidence and anxiety that we often associate with this characteristic.
这种情况发生在一个人的自我批判极其严重的时候。他们感到有巨大的压力要去做到最好，并且他们担心其他人会拒绝他们，特别是他们生命中重要、受人尊敬的人，我想到了父母，我想到了老师。通常，可感知的外部标准，如学业期望，会导致这种版本的完美主义以及我们经常与这种特征联系在一起的随之而来的低自信和焦虑。
Perfectionists who are other-oriented, they hold others to particularly high standards. It is very hard to build relationships under these conditions. And it can be really detrimental for social well-being because one slight imperfection in someone else that can cause this perfectionist, this person, to completely shut them out. So it's highly detrimental.
其他导向的完美主义者，他们对别人抱有特别高的标准。在这些条件下建立关系是非常困难的。这对社会福祉可能非常有害，因为别人身上的一点点不完美就会导致这个完美主义者、这个人彻底把他们拒之门外。所以它是极具破坏性的。
And finally, we have the self-oriented perfectionist. they are very organized. They are very conscientious. They are very type A. They set high standards for themselves in their lives and their careers, but they are also able to go after their goals. So high self-oriented perfectionism, it's generally associated with the most adaptive traits correlated with things like greater productivity, success, assertiveness, great focus. These people, they show, I guess, higher rates of the positive emotions and the motivation and the successes that we sometimes associate with perfectionism. Now, I don't personally believe there is a healthy version of perfectionism, but if there was to be one,
最后，我们有自我导向型完美主义者。他们非常有组织性。他们非常认真负责。他们是非常A型人格的人。他们在生活和职业中为自己设定了高标准，但他们也能够去追求自己的目标。因此，高度的自我导向型完美主义，它通常与最具适应性的特质相关联，与更高的生产力、成功、自信、高度专注等事情相关。这些人，我猜，表现出更高比率的积极情绪、动机和成功，而这些有时是我们与完美主义联系在一起的。现在，我个人不认为存在一种健康的完美主义，但如果一定要有的话，
it would be those who are self-oriented. You know, their relationships are not under scrutiny. And most of the time, those who fall into this category, they're not behaving in a way that's looking to fulfill someone else's expectations, but their own. However, there is a caveat, because regardless of what category you sit in, you're still going to exhibit those core characteristics,
那将是那些自我导向的人。你知道，他们的关系没有受到严密审视。而且大多数时候，那些属于这一类的人，他们的行为不是为了满足别人的期望，而是为了他们自己的期望。然而，有一个警告，因为无论你属于哪一类，你仍然会表现出那些核心特征，
like a fear of failure, placing incredible pressure on yourself or others, and you're still at a risk of burnout and anxiety. So now that we have a grasp on the basics, what are the exact origins of perfectionism? Well, according to psychology, the major ones are societal or familial factors, including early childhood experiences. That one always seems to be the culprit, but also things like personality. and self-concept, and finally, comorbid conditions like ADHD or OCD. First off, our upbringing. This is going to play a large role in whether you are someone who exhibits perfectionist traits or not,
比如对失败的恐惧，给自己或他人施加巨大的压力，并且你仍然面临精疲力竭和焦虑的风险。现在我们已经掌握了基础知识，完美主义的确切起源是什么？好吧，根据心理学的说法，主要的因素是社会或家庭因素，包括童年早期的经历。这似乎总是罪魁祸首，但还有诸如个性之类的东西。和自我概念，最后是诸如多动症或强迫症之类的共病。首先，我们的成长环境。这将在很大程度上决定你是否是一个表现出完美主义特质的人，
particularly if you had parents or caregivers who had really high standards for you, particularly academic standards, this has passed on to you as you learn to, internalize their expectations, especially if their expectations were reinforced by punishment or variable reward because their beliefs are being reinforced by something you're either wishing to avoid or wanting to obtain. We've spoken about this before, I think many times, but we know that young children, they have a really strong desire to please their caregivers because they are the source of our security, the source of our support, and to an extent, our self-esteem. It's all drawn from our parents, as Freud would say. And I think further to that, children are
特别是如果你有父母或照顾者对你抱有非常高的标准，特别是学业标准，这些标准在你学会将他们的期望内化时传递给了你，特别是如果他们的期望是通过惩罚或可变奖励来得到强化的，因为他们的信仰正在被你希望避免或想要获得的东西所强化。我们之前讨论过这个，我想有很多次了，但我们知道小孩子们有一种非常强烈的渴望去讨好他们的照顾者，因为他们是我们安全的来源、支持的来源，并在一定程度上是我们自尊的来源。这一切都源于我们的父母，正如弗洛伊德所说。我认为除此之外，孩子们
incredibly vulnerable. And they're also learning the ways of the world. And their main point of reference on what is correct is from their parents. So if your parents convince you that perfectionism is what is expected, you have no other point of reference to either confirm or deny this standard. And if an adult tells a small child that they are a failure, that they're not working hard enough, they're not smart enough, they're not talented, that child will internalize this message and they will believe that it's true and continue to find evidence to support this point of view and continue to try and also find a way to prove it wrong. It's this weird catch-22 in which we still believe that we are failures, but we work so hard to prove ourselves
极其脆弱。他们也在学习世事之道。他们关于什么是正确的的主要参考点来自于他们的父母。因此，如果你的父母让你相信完美主义是人们所期望的，你就没有其他参考点来确认或否定这个标准。如果一个成年人告诉一个小孩子他们是一个失败者，他们工作不够努力，他们不够聪明，他们没有天赋，那个孩子就会内化这个信息，并且他们会相信这是真的，并继续寻找证据来支持这个观点，并继续尝试同时也找到一种证明它是错的方法。这是一个奇怪的两难困境，在这种困境中，我们仍然相信自己是失败者，但我们非常努力地去证明自己
wrong. An additional link is that perfectionism can also be learned by children who are growing up around really highly successful perfectionist parents. If your parent is an incredibly successful athlete. Maybe they were really academically talented and they tell you that they're a CEO, they're doing great things. We model this behavior and this expectation and we implicitly look to be that way as well. Perfectionism is also encouraged when children are exclusively praised for their achievements rather than for their inherent value or their efforts or their progress. There is a scene in The Help. I know it's a strange caveat, strange tangent, but there's this scene where Abelene Viola Davis's character tells this young girl that she is kind, that she is smart, that she is important.
错了。另一个联系是，在那些在非常成功的完美主义父母身边长大的孩子身上，完美主义也可以被学会。如果你的父母是一个非常成功的运动员。也许他们在学术上很有天赋，他们告诉你他们是首席执行官，他们在做伟大的事情。我们模仿这种行为和这种期望，我们也含蓄地希望成为那样的人。当孩子们仅仅因为他们的成就而受到赞扬，而不是因为他们内在的价值、他们的努力或他们的进步时，完美主义也会受到鼓励。在《相助》里有一个场景。我知道这是一个奇怪的警告，奇怪的离题，但有这样一个场景，维奥拉·戴维斯扮演的角色阿伯琳告诉这个年轻女孩，她是善良的，她是聪明的，她是重要的。
And those are incredibly powerful affirmations to tell a child because they're about their core inherent value rather than about what they can achieve, rather than about their grades. or how beautiful they are or how perfect they are. Our innate self-concept and our personality is, of course, another factor. Personality, it's otherwise known as temperament, and it's something that we are born with, and perfectionism is, after all, a part of that, because it's a personality trait. Of course, there are environmental factors,
这些是告诉一个孩子的极其强大的肯定，因为它们关乎他们核心的内在价值，而不是关乎他们能取得什么成就，而不是关乎他们的成绩。或者他们有多美丽或者他们有多完美。我们天生的自我概念和个性，当然是另一个因素。个性，也就是众所周知的气质，是我们生来就有的东西，而完美主义毕竟是其中的一部分，因为它是一种人格特质。当然，有环境因素，
but you would be surprised how much of it is contained in our DNA. It's the age-old debate of nature versus, nurture. And I think when it comes to perfectionism, it really is a mix of both. Finally, we did discuss this before, but there are certain mental health conditions that have a really strong cause of relationship with perfectionism, in particular, OCD and ADHD. Perfectionism, it's actually one of the most common cognitive distortions reported in adults with ADHD. So there have been studies that have shown a strong correlation between perfectionism and impulsivity, which is another symptom of ADHD. And together, they form somewhat of a negative feedback loop in which someone
但你会惊讶于其中有多少是包含在我们的DNA中的。这是天性与后天养育的古老争论。我认为当谈到完美主义时，它确实是两者的结合。最后，我们之前讨论过，有一些心理健康状况与完美主义有着非常强的因果关系，特别是强迫症和多动症。完美主义，它其实是成年多动症患者报告的最常见的认知扭曲之一。因此，有研究表明完美主义与冲动性之间存在很强的相关性，而冲动性是多动症的另一个症状。它们共同形成了一种某种程度上的负面反馈循环，其中有人
with ADHD will set impossible standards. They will fail to meet them and make rash decisions out of frustration. And these decisions often further reinforce not only this pattern of behavior, but this idea that they're a failure, which is really sad. It's incredibly sad, but it shows how much of our brain really has something to do with this. I think the link between perfectionism and OCD is a little bit more obvious. Research has repeatedly shown that people with perfectionism, tendencies are much more likely to have OCD and the explanation that they give is that they're probably linked to an imbalance of certain chemicals or neurotransmitters in the brain like dopamine and gluten-mate which is why our brain can't really regulate our behaviors and has all these
患有多动症的人会设定不可能的标准。他们将无法达到这些标准，并出于沮丧做出轻率的决定。而这些决定往往进一步强化了这种行为模式，而且强化了他们是失败者的这种想法，这真的很悲哀。这极其悲哀，但它表明我们的大脑在多大程度上真的与此有关。我认为完美主义和强迫症之间的联系要明显得多。研究一再表明，有完美主义倾向的人更有可能患有强迫症，他们给出的解释是，这些可能与大脑中某些化学物质或神经递质（如多巴胺和谷氨酸盐）的不平衡有关，这就是为什么我们的大脑无法真正调节我们的行为，并且围绕控制以及需要控制结果以及需要结果是完美的或达到某个标准有所有这些奇怪的结构。但我要停止闲逛了。我现在真正想谈的是完美主义与学业焦虑或学业表现是如何相互作用的。关于这一点已经有很多研究了。当我告诉你这一点时，这是难以置信的，它甚至创造了自己的术语。它被称为学业完美主义。国家卫生研究院的一项研究发现
weird structures around control and needing to control an outcome and needing the outcome to be perfect or to a certain standard. But I'm going to stop dilly-dallying. What I really want to talk about now is how perfectionism and academic anxiety or performance interact. There have been so many studies on this. When I tell you that, it's unbelievable and it's even coined its own term. It's called academic perfectionism. One study by the National Institute of Health found
那些具有高度完美主义担忧的人在面对他们几乎无法控制的对完美主义的追求时，会经历增加的绝望感和缺乏控制感，从而导致瘫痪和较低的学业表现。现在当我谈到瘫痪时，并不是说他们身体瘫痪了，而是他们的大脑几乎无法说服他们去执行一项活动，除非他们知道它是完美的。这很有道理，对吧？如果你严重关注你的表现，这会使你很难集中注意力，因为没有什么是“刚刚好”的。有时它需要刚刚好，但你不会允许自己这样做。你需要它是完美的，坦率地说，我认为这是不可能的。所以发生的事情是他们发现自己完全陷入困境。
that people with high perfectionistic worries experienced increased feelings of hopelessness and a lack of control in the face of their almost uncontrollable pursuit of perfectionism resulting in paralysis and lower academic performance. Now when I say paralysis, it's not that they were physically paralyzed, it's that their brain almost couldn't convince them to perform an activity unless they knew it was perfect. And that makes a lot of sense, right? If you are severely concerned with your performance, it makes it really hard to focus because nothing can be just good enough. Sometimes it needs to be good enough, but you won't allow yourself to do that. You need it to be perfect, which is, quite frankly, I think, impossible. So what happens is they find themselves completely stuck.
或者一遍又一遍地重做某事，直到它达到他们的标准，也许在论文截止日期过去几天之后。如果是一篇论文或者如果是一项活动或任务，甚至早就该完成了。最近很多文献都一再承认，完美主义，特别是在15到24岁的人群中，正在上升。这些人大多数在这个年龄段都在做什么呢？好吧，他们在学习。我认为这种学业完美主义和焦虑的上升真的归因于巨大的文化和社会压力
or redoing something over and over again until it reaches their standard, perhaps days after the, you know, if it's an essay or if it's an activity or a task, is even due. And it's been repeatedly acknowledged in a lot of literature lately that perfectionism, particularly amongst 15 to 24 year olds, is on the rise. And what are most people doing between those ages? well, they're studying. And I think this rise in academic perfectionism and anxiety really comes down to the immense amount of cultural and societal pressure
社会把我们放在首位，要求我们做到最好。你知道，现在的世界太专注于竞争和成功了，这确实助长了社会比较以及对完美成绩和学业成就的追求。这对年轻人有很多蔓延效应，特别是当他们处于黄金期和形成期以及进行某种形式的学习时。如果我们只看成绩和单纯的成绩，我们可能会被误导，认为完美主义是一种积极的品质，我们知道它不是。我们已经揭穿了这一点，
that's been placed on us to be the best. You know, the world these days is so focused on competition and success and that really fuels social comparison and the pursuit of perfect grades and academic achievement. And this has a lot of bleed-on effects to young people, particularly when they're in their prime and formative years and also undertaking some form of study. If we are only looking at grades and grades alone, we might be confused into thinking that perfectionism is a positive quality, which we know it's not. We've debunked that already,
但在某些方面，学业完美主义，它与学业表现呈正相关。但它也与整体幸福感呈负相关。所以具有这种品质、这种特质的人，他们在表面上可能做得很好。一切看起来都很棒。但在内部，他们给自己施加的压力是一个巨大的负担，侵蚀着他们的心理健康，侵蚀着他们的关系、他们的空闲时间、他们的整体幸福感。而这些研究中真正有趣的是，大多数有完美主义倾向的学生实际上在告诉研究人员他们的表现真的很差，或者他们没有取得好成绩，或者他们在客观上有天赋时并没有在学术上有天赋，但当被要求自己评估这种品质或他们的表现时，他们仍然认为自己不够好。这就是学业完美主义以及一般完美主义的悖论。
but in some ways, academic perfectionism, it is positively correlated with academic performance. but it's also negatively correlated with overall well-being. So people with this quality, with this trait, they may be doing well on the outside. Everything looks great. But internally, the pressure they place on themselves is an immense burden that eats into their mental health, eats into their relationships, their free time, their overall well-being. And what's really interesting about some of these studies is that most students who had perfectionism were actually telling the researchers that they were performing really poorly or that they weren't getting good grades or that they weren't academically gifted when objectively they were, but when they were asked to rate that quality or their performance themselves, they still didn't see themselves as good enough. And that's the catch-22 of academic perfectionism and perfectionism in general.
没有什么会永远足够好。我们的现状是以我们的失败来看待自己。现在我承诺过我会谈论拖延症，因为它是完美主义的一个必不可少的组成部分，特别是当它与学业焦虑有关时。拖延症，实际上是把事情推迟，不是因为我们没有能力。而是因为我们觉得在精神上还没有准备好去执行或完成任务。有时这归结为自我批判。当然，罪魁祸首还是完美主义。
Nothing is ever going to be good enough. Our status quo is to view ourselves by our failures. Now I promised I'd talk about procrastination because it is an essential component of perfectionism, especially as it relates to academic anxiety. Procrastination, really it's about putting things off, not because we're not capable. but because we don't feel mentally prepared to perform or complete the task. And what this sometimes comes down to is self-criticism. And of course, the main culprit, perfectionism.
我们被这样一种想法压垮了：我们产出的东西不会是完美的。因此，我们习惯性地甚至避免开始它或去做它。这种心态基本上是，除非是完美的，否则我不会做某事，所以我甚至无法开始。我记得有一次我和我的一个朋友在大学里时的讨论。她是那种会把论文留到最后一分钟的人。她总是要求延期。我和她在图书馆坐了几个小时，然后意识到当我们离开时
We become overwhelmed by the idea that what we produce won't be perfect. And therefore, we habitually avoid even starting it or doing it. The mentality is basically, I'm not going to do something unless, it's perfect, so I cannot even start. And I remember a discussion I had with a friend of mine back when we were at university together. She was one of these people who would leave essays to the last minute. She would always be requesting extensions. I'd sit down in the library with her for hours and then realize by the time we'd left
她甚至还没有开始我们计划在那天完成的论文，愿上帝保佑她。她是这个星球上最甜美的人之一。但她对我说了一些话，这真的让我重新思考了我现在所知道的她的完美主义倾向，那就是如果她从未尝试过，她就不会失败。她太沉迷于追求完美，而她的自尊心已经被这个习惯削弱了，以至于她被自己的标准搞得瘫痪了，甚至无法尝试她所害怕的事情。这不仅是我们的成绩和学业表现存在问题，还有许多其他与我们的二十多岁相关的领域，比如申请研究生
that she hadn't even begun the essay we were planning to finish that day and God love her. She is one of the sweetest people on this planet. But she said something to me that really made me rethink what I now know were her perfectionist tendencies, and that is that if she never tried, she couldn't fail. She was so absorbed in being perfect and her self-esteem was already weakened by this habit that she became paralyzed by her standards and she couldn't even attempt the thing that she was fearing. It's not just our grades and our academic performance where this is, is a problem, but a lot of other areas that are pertinent to our 20s, like applying for graduate
工作，做出生活选择，比如去哪个大学，住在哪里，甚至是极度微不足道的问题和决定，因为我们太纠结于这种想法：这需要是完美的。这需要是正确的决定。我不能犯错。我不能以某种方式让自己走上一条通往失败的道路。当你处于这种心态时，当你陷入僵局时，这可能是如此令人压抑。事实是，你永远不可能完美。很抱歉打破你的幻想，但这只是，我猜，现实。
jobs, making life choices such as where to go to university, where to live, even super minor questions and decisions because we get so caught up in this idea of this needs to be perfect. This needs to be the right decision. I cannot make a mistake. I cannot somehow put myself on a path towards failure. and when you are in this mentality, when you are stuck in a rut, it can be so crushing. The truth is, you can never be perfect. Sorry to burst your bubble, but that's just, I guess, reality.
随着我们年龄的增长，我想我们都会学到一些东西，但是我们如何能将这种理解融入到我们的日常行为中，并克服我们的完美主义倾向呢？这不是死刑，这不是无期徒刑。有些事情我们可以做。所以所有这些以及更多内容将在稍后揭晓。百分之二。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数就是这个数字。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And something I think we all learn as we get older, but how can we integrate this understanding into our everyday behavior and move past our perfectionist tendencies? It's not a deaf sentence, it's not a live sentence. There are things that we can do. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中心的精神坚韧、健身和建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。
And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, you're more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《百分之二》。也就是i-Hart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方的2%。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMAs上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集中，我们都挑选一个...这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为可卡因。我愿意一整天都谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a... here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在桌上也有艾滋病，所以。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为没有更重要的年份了。对于黑人。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是对于黑人来说最重要的年份之一
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year. for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people
在美国历史上。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难中学习》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖姆斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将把我在
in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the
心理健康领域以及与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们处于对事物的追求中时，我们太过于陷入追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个东西，而我们仍在追逐它，并且我们不知道什么时候我们已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现在世时做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？
mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid?
心理健康领域以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我指的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是你觉得自己是个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear. games is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in soans, correct?
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我只想让你真正成为一个好人。加入我，Kear. games 在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们围绕疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，欧恩斯女士，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《情网难逃》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧恩斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧恩斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你获取
podcasts. I've said it once. I'm going to say it again. Life is not about being perfect. And if you go through life believing that it is, Your happiness is always going to rest on your next failure, and I can assure you that there will be many, many in our 20s, many in our 30s, many in our entire lives. So we need to learn how to either live with that reality or manage our perfectionism in a sustainable manner. And I personally would choose the latter. There is a hard truth to swallow, though.
播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我已经说过一次了。我还要再说一遍。生活不是为了追求完美。如果你带着这种信念度过一生，你的幸福将永远建立在你的下一次失败之上，我可以向你保证，在我们二十多岁的时候会有很多很多次失败，三十多岁的时候会有很多，贯穿我们整个人生都会有很多。所以我们需要学会如何与这种现实共存，或者以可持续的方式管理我们的完美主义。而我个人会选择后者。不过，这是一个很难接受的残酷真相。
This isn't going to be easy. if our assumptions about the origins of perfectionism are correct in that it is derived from our upbringing and internal unconscious elements of our personality and character these are hard things to change you cannot go back to your childhood and change how your parents spoke to you you cannot reach into your brain and rearrange what it looks like in there but it's not impossible and i do think the benefits definitely, definitely outweigh the effort. Imagine what it's going to be like to do something and just be happy with it rather than fighting the urge to repeatedly go back and fix things or stress for days about whether what you did was perfect. It's really liberating to let go of some of that anxiety
这并不容易。如果我们关于完美主义起源的假设是正确的，即它源于我们的成长经历以及我们个性和性格中内在的无意识元素，这些是很难改变的事情。你不能回到童年去改变父母对你说话的方式；你无法把手伸进大脑去重新排列里面的结构，但这并非不可能，而且我认为其带来的好处绝对、绝对大于付出的努力。想象一下，做一件事并为此感到高兴，而不是去压抑那种想要反复回去修改事情的冲动，或者连续几天为自己做的事情是否完美而感到压力，那将会是怎样的体验。放下其中一部分焦虑，
and some of that stress. And there are a few incredible methods that I would personally use for this. I do use for this. I'm definitely someone with perfectionist tendencies, even when making these episodes. I'm just going to break the fourth wall here, but I find it so hard to relinquish control. And if something isn't exactly how I want it to be, if someone says something about how my voice was annoying, or I pronounce something wrong, I spend like days thinking over it and wanting to change like this one small thing that like either no one notices or like one to two people. But I think it got a lot easier for me when I realized that that it's just how my brain operates, but also that I can control my cognitions and my interpretation and my perspective of these events. A practice that I've
以及一部分压力，真的会让人感到无比解脱。而且有一些非常棒的方法是我个人会使用的。我也确实在用这些方法。我绝对是一个有完美主义倾向的人，甚至在制作这些节目时也是如此。我在这里就打破一下第四面墙吧，但我发现要放权是如此困难。如果事情不完全如我所愿，如果有人说我的声音很讨厌，或者我某个词发音不对，我会花好几天时间去琢磨它，想要改变这件微不足道的小事——而这件小事要么没人注意到，要么只有一两个人注意到。但我觉得，当我意识到这只是我大脑运作的方式，而且我也能够控制自己对这些事件的认知、解读和视角时，一切就变得容易多了。我采用的一种
adopted is the 80-20 rule. Now, I don't know where I heard this for the first time, but since hearing about it, it is a massive part of my life. And I googled it because I was like, is this a big thing that I just have never, like I've heard of it once and I've never gone back? But no, it actually typically refers to the idea that 80% of our results come from only 20% of our efforts. I think it's called like the parado rule or something like that. But how I like to think of it is that an outcome in which 80% is perfect and the other 20% is okay or average. is still a good outcome if it saves me time and it saves me anxiety. Striving for 80% on a test or getting 80% of your daily tasks done,
做法是80/20法则。现在，我不记得我是从哪里第一次听到这个概念的，但自从听说之后，它就成为了我生活中的一个巨大组成部分。我还用谷歌搜索了一下，因为我想，这是一个很大的概念，而我以前从来没听过吗？就像我以前听说过一次就再也没关注过？但事实并非如此，它实际上通常指的是这样一个观点：我们80%的成果仅来自于20%的努力。我想这被称为帕累托法则之类的东西。但我喜欢这样想：一个结果中80%是完美的，其余20%是凑合的或一般的，如果它能为我节省时间和焦虑，那它依然是一个好结果。在考试中争取80%的分数，或者完成你日常任务的80%，
it's better than 0% if we let ourselves be, you know, paralyzed. And that other 20% is negligent. It doesn't matter. And I think this idea allows our brain to compromise with itself. We don't need to, you know, entirely give up our standards. but when they are coming at the expense of important things in life like balance, like friendship and the time to actually enjoy the good, joyful things, we should be okay with adjusting our expectations slightly.
如果我们让自己陷入那种瘫痪状态，80%也总比0%要好。而那另外20%是可以忽略不计的。这并不重要。我认为这个理念让大脑能够与自己妥协。我们不需要，你知道的，完全放弃我们的标准，但当这些标准是以牺牲生活中重要的事情为代价时，比如平衡、比如友情以及真正去享受那些美好、快乐时光的时间，我们应该能够欣然接受并稍微调整我们的期望。
So I always say to myself, 80-20 rule. 80-20 rule, it's okay if 80% of it is perfect, and 20% of it is not exactly how you would like it, but it's still got done. Another defining feature of perfectionism, particularly when it comes to academic perfectionism and academic anxiety, is this unhealthy focus on our failures compared to our successes. This is what we call a compulsive preoccupation, and when we only think about the times that we haven't met our goals or we have quote unquote failed, it can really lead to a distorted self-image. A friend of mine told me about an incredible strategy the other day called Grab the Bullet Visualization.
所以我总是对自己说：80/20法则。80/20法则，就算80%是完美的，另外20%不完全是你想要的那个样子，也没关系，但事情终究是完成了。完美主义的另一个显著特征，特别是在涉及学业完美主义和学业焦虑时，是我们对失败的病态关注，相比之下我们对成功的关注却很少。这就是我们所说的强迫性专注，当我们满脑子想的都是那些没有达到目标、或者所谓的“失败”的时刻时，它确实会导致扭曲的自我形象。前几天，一个朋友跟我分享了一个非常棒的策略，叫做“抓住子弹可视化”。
I don't know if this is a real thing, but the way she explained it to me was so powerful that I had to share it. I was sitting down with her I was just talking about something that had happened. It was this tiny mistake and I was obsessing over it. I had this compulsive preoccupation and I couldn't get over it. And she said to me, the idea that you need to think of, the visualisation, that you need to have is that life is going to throw us a lot of obstacles or so-called bullets.
我不知道这是否是一个真实存在的概念，但她向我解释的方式太有力量了，以至于我不得不把它分享出来。当时我正和她坐在一起，聊着刚刚发生的一件小事。那是一个极其微小的错误，而我却一直在为此耿耿于怀。我有这种强迫性的专注，而且无法走出来。她对我说，你需要去思考的这个理念，你需要有的视觉化练习，那就是生活会向我们抛出许多障碍，或者说“子弹”。
And bullets are fast. But when we slow down, we can effortlessly grab the bullet, grab the failure and throw it aside. Failure is the bullet. Slow down, take it in, learn the lesson, and imagine yourself picking this tiny bullet from the air, not letting it hit you, and throwing it away. You don't need to keep it. That's what we need to do with failure. Imagine yourself grabbing failure, in this case a bullet so that we can visualize it in the air, examining it for a second, learning the lesson, and then being done with it. And visualization, not just this exercise, but many other types, is a fantastic psychological technique for
子弹是飞快的。但当我们慢下来时，我们可以轻而易举地抓住子弹，抓住失败，然后把它抛在一边。失败就是子弹。慢下来，去体会它，吸取教训，想象自己从空中摘下这颗小小的子弹，不让它击中你，然后把它扔掉。你不需要留着它。这就是我们需要对失败做的事情。想象自己抓住失败——在这个例子中是一颗子弹，以便我们能在空中将其实视化——端详它一会儿，吸取教训，然后就此放下。而可视化，不仅是这个练习，还有许多其他类型的可视化，是一种极好的心理学技术，它能通过把我们的想法置于新的语境中或将其视为可控的来重新聚焦我们的思维，使其变得富有成效。所以，如果你是一个完美主义者，把你的问题视觉化真的会非常有用，尤其是把它想象成有点荒谬或富于想象力的东西。
refocusing our thoughts to be productive by imagining them in a new context or as manageable. So if you are a perfectionist, it can be really good to visualize your problem, especially as something that's a little bit ridiculous or imaginative. Positive self-talk is also such an important part of our toolkit. And this really goes for everyone, even those who aren't struggling with perfectionism or academic anxiety. It's essential, I think, for successfully managing failure and minimizing the impact that our unattainable standards have on our self-respect, have on our self-esteem, have on our well-being. We are no strangers to this idea on the podcast. We talked about it recently,
积极的自我对话也是我们工具箱中非常重要的一部分。这确实适用于每个人，甚至包括那些没有在与完美主义或学业焦虑作斗争的人。我认为，这对于成功应对失败、最大限度地减少我们无法达到的标准对我们的自尊、自信和福祉的影响至关重要。我们在播客中对这个观点并不陌生。其实我们最近在关于“幸运女孩综合症心理学”的那期节目中讨论过它。如果你听过那一期，你就会很熟悉了。但是，积极的自我对话，它源于心理学的一个学科，或者说子学科，叫做积极心理学。它涉及培养一种内部对话，让你对自己感觉良好。使用诸如“我不仅仅是我的成就”、“我是个有趣的人”、“我有价值”、“我很自信”之类的话语。
actually, in our episode on the psychology of Lucky Girl Syndrome. If you listen to that, you'll be familiar. But positive self-talk, it comes from this discipline, I guess, sub-discipline of psychology called positive psychology. And it involves cultivating an internal dialogue that makes you feel good about yourself. Using phrases like, I am more than my accomplishments. I am an interesting person. I am valuable. I am confident.
我的未来不由我的失败来定义。把这些当作你每天重复的咒语，或者在事情变得艰难、你遭遇挫折时默念，这可能会改变你的人生。记住，我们对自己说话的方式会影响我们的行为，也会影响我们的视角。我觉得这甚至不用多说，毕竟这是一个心理学播客，但疗法确实能发挥奇效，特别是如果你能找到一位专门从事认知行为疗法（又称CBT）的心理学家。毕竟，完美主义是一种思维模式。它是一种影响我们行为、思维模式的特质，因此也影响着我们如何看待自己的问题、失败和成功。但如果你追溯到根源，
My future is not defined by my failures. And treating these like mantras that you repeat every day or when things get tough or you face a setback can be life-changing. Remember, the way that we speak to ourselves will impact our behaviour and will impact our perspective. I think it also goes without saying this is a psychology podcast after all, but therapy can do wonders, especially if you get a psychologist that specialises in cognitive behavioural therapy, otherwise known as CBT. Perfectionism is, after all, a thought pattern. It's a trait that influences our behaviors, our thought patterns, and therefore how we view our problems and our failures and our successes. But if you go back to the root
也就是我们的认知，并把它转变成更积极的东西，其后续产生的连锁反应会非常强大。所以CBT的全部前提是，我们的行为受我们的想法影响。如果我们改变自己的想法，如果我们剖析它们，如果我们将其合理化，那么我们的行为就会改变，我们就会得到想要的积极结果。所以我真的强烈推荐它，特别是如果你是一个完美主义者，对学业焦虑或生活中任何方面的焦虑感到特别担忧的话。试着找一位专注于CBT的治疗师。这需要时间，但正如我之前所说，你会开始感到无比解脱。这些问题对你来说将不再是问题。
cause, that being our cognitions, and alter it to something more positive, the flow on effects can be really powerful. So the whole premise of CBT is that our behaviors influenced by our thoughts, if we change our thoughts, if we break them down, if we rationalize them, then our behavior will change and we will get the positive outcomes that we want. So I would really recommend it, especially if you are a perfectionist who is particularly worried about academic anxiety or anxiety really in any part of your life. Try and find a therapist who specializes in CBT. It will take time, but like I said before, you will begin to feel so liberated. These problems will not be problems for you anymore.
你不会再感到那种必须完美的压力。而且我认为世界会变得美好得多。这是今天给你的最后提醒。你不需要完美。我们正面临着这样一个不断变化的社会，每个人都如此关注成功、财富、完美的成绩、令人印象深刻的简历，但事情其实不必如此。
You won't feel that pressure to be perfect. And I think the world just becomes a lot more enjoyable. Here is your final reminder of the day. You do not need to be perfect. We are facing this changing society in which everyone is so concerned with success, with wealth, with perfect grades, with impressive resumes, and it doesn't have to be that way.
你偶尔被允许失败。生活中的任何事情都不完美。爱情不完美。大自然不完美。音乐不完美。艺术不完美。而你和这些事物一样美丽且复杂。所以你被允许拥有一些瑕疵。
You're allowed to sometimes fail. Nothing in life is perfect. Love isn't perfect. Nature isn't perfect. Music isn't perfect. Art isn't perfect. And you are just as beautiful and complex as those things. So you're allowed to have some flaws.
它只是为你的生活增添了质感。它让我们变得更加有趣。我也认为，错误、失败和瑕疵能够塑造性格，它们教会我们非凡的课程。关键在于真正去思考：我的生活值得为了一个学业成果、为了一个特定的分数、为了让某件事变得无可挑剔而彻底把自己逼死吗？我认为不值得。生活并不是由那些东西组成的，你知道的，特别是如果你现在是大学甚至高中的学生的话。我知道，我知道有很多20岁以下的人在听这个节目。我向你保证，你的成绩在五年内不会有什么影响，可能连两年都不会有。
It just brings texture to your life. It makes us much more interesting. I think also mistakes and failures. and flaws, they build character, they teach us incredible lessons. And it's about really thinking about is my life worth completely killing myself for an academic outcome, for a particular grade, for something to be flawless? I don't think it is. Life is not made up of those things, you know, especially if you're someone in university or even high school right now. I know, I know there's a of people under the age of 20 who listen to this. I promise you that your grades are not going to
比如，我根本不记得我在大学时任何一门课程考了多少分。我不记得，你知道的，某次只占我某个科目20分数的测试结果。比如，那些事情对我来说已经不重要了。当我回想起那段时光时，我真正记得的是我遇到的那些了不起的朋友。我确实记得。我记得。我记得我曾拥有过的所有酷炫机会，去做了那些激动人心的事，去做那些与学业成绩毫无关系的事。我只是觉得这是一个非常值得一提的提醒。有时我们需要听到它。我知道，如果你是一个完美主义者，这要困难得多，因为它可能根深蒂固。但我真的鼓励你去考虑一些其他的
matter in five years, probably not even two. Like, I do not remember what I got on any of my courses when I was at university. I don't remember, you know, a test result that was only worth 20% of one of my subjects. Like, those things don't matter to me anymore. When I think back to that time, what I do remember is the amazing friends that I met. I do remember. I do. remember all the cool opportunities that I had to do exciting things, to do things that had nothing to do with academic results. And I do just think that's a worthwhile reminder. Sometimes we need to hear it. I know that if you are a perfectionist, it's a lot harder because it can be so innate. But I would really encourage you to think about some of the other
选择。想想你如何克服这个障碍，并将生活视作不完美的。非常感谢收听今天的节目。希望你喜欢。希望你有所收获，献给我所有目前仍在大学、仍在学校、仍在艰难前行的人们。致以热烈的祝贺。我想我无法回去再参加一次考试或再写一篇论文了。那简直会是，天哪，太可怕了。
options. Think about how you can overcome this obstacle and view life as imperfect. Thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I hope you enjoyed it. I hope you learned something for all of my people out there who are currently still in uni, still in school, still slugging your way. Big congratulations. I do not think I could go back and do another exam or write another essay. It would just be, oh my God, awful.
所以，特别是如果你正在应对一点学业焦虑，希望这能为你提供一个关于“为什么”的解释以及一些下一步的行动方案；或者如果你一直在严重拖延，完美主义就是其中一种解释。所以我希望这能给你带来一些启发。我很享受制作这期节目。如果你有某个特定的主题、想法或话题希望我探讨，请在 Instagram 上关注我 @That Psychology Podcast。我非常喜欢接受大家的节目建议。我喜欢你们替我做这份工作并给我提供灵感。所以请去那边关注我吧。如果你愿意的话，给我发个信息。
So especially if you're dealing with a bit of academic anxiety, hopefully this provided you with an explanation as to why and some of the next steps or if you are procrastinating a lot, perfectionism is one explanation. So I hope it gave you something to think about. I really enjoyed making this episode. If there is a particular subject or idea or topic that you would like me to cover, please follow me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. I love taking episode suggestions. I love when you guys do my job for me and give me my ideas. So please follow me over there. If you would like to do so, send me a message.
我很期待听到你的声音。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，如果你觉得你的朋友、家人或同事——你生活中的任何人——需要听到这个，请分享给他们。你可能会改变他们的一天。你可能会改变他们的月份。你可能会改变他们的人生。也许不会。
I would love to hear from you. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, if you think that you have a friend or a family member or a work colleague, anyone in your life who needs to hear this, share it with them. You could change their day. You could change their month. You could change their life. Maybe not.
但还是分享出去吧。一如既往，如果你有此意愿，请在苹果播客、Spotify 或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这有助于节目的成长。这有助于触达新的人群。这也确实能让我的一天变得美好。听到你们令人难以置信的积极评价让我感到无比快乐。我真的把它们都读了。有时我甚至会感动得有点落泪。
But share it along. And as always, if you feel cold to do so, leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. It helps the show to grow. It helps to reach new people. And it also just makes my day. It makes me so happy to hear your incredibly positive reviews. I do read them all. And sometimes I get a little bit teary.
所以如果你想看我哭，这就是最简单的方法。老样子，我们周五会带着另一期节目回归。到时见。2%。这是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWA% 在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你
So if you want to see me cry, that's the easiest way to do so. As always, we will be back on Friday for another episode. See you then. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。来自1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方说其实都不安全，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，欧恩斯女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《情网难逃》（Love Trapped）。劳拉。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura.
斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧恩斯终于面临后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。
Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。